intense fighting is taking place on the
streets around the Army Headquarters and
presidential Palace in hartum as the
conflict between the Sudanese Army and
the paramilitary group the rapid support
forces enters its third week
both sides say they're making gains and
both blame each other for violating yet
another ceasefire
the Army says it's repelled an attack on
jabalia 40 kilometers south of hatum it
blames the rapid support forces for the
continuing violence the rsf denies this
and says it's taken control of an area
south of the capital
we convey good news to our commander and
tell him that the battles are over and
that the remnant groups have fled the
main Market is back to normal now and
the rapid support forces are welcomed by
the people
thank you
the UN Envoy has reiterated calls for a
permanent end to the violence and issued
this warning
Regional countries and the International
Community must say that if the situation
continues even if one side wins the
fight that side would not be accepted
internationally if Assad refuses
negotiations and refuses reconciliation
it will not be accepted internationally
regionally and I think also nationally
in Sudan
Sudan doctors Union has warned the
health services on the verge of collapse
and says there's a shortage of medicine
this hospital is in the city of onderman
we lack medical staff and Facilities our
shifts have been extended but there are
only one or two doctors to cover two or
three departments in normal
circumstances this wouldn't happen but
now the situation is so difficult
with essential supplies running out
thousands of streaming out of the
country many are heading to Port Sudan
on the Eastern Red Sea Coast
I was among the people trapped for
nearly seven days in Khartoum with no
food electricity or water the conditions
were very bad but thank God we managed
to leave and come here the journey was a
bit difficult but things worked out and
we arrived
now they wait to register for a ferry to
Saudi Arabia relieved to be out of
immediate danger but uncertain about
when it will be safe to return Victoria
gate and B Al Jazeera